ignore the non-believers if you have an
idea you're gonna have people in your
life who are doubters who don't believe
in what you're doing who will tell you
to do the safe thing the smart thing and
go get a job that your dream is just not
possible this is a stupid idea you're
gonna have a lot of those people in your
life especially if you have a big idea
and this is a really dangerous and
critical time for you because an ideas a
special thing you wake up one morning
and you've got a great idea to change
the world and then all you get hit with
is negativity people saying no no no no
no no I'm telling you all the reasons
why it's not gonna work out and it's so
dangerous because you haven't figured
out all the answers yet you have a
vision for what you want the world to
look like but you don't quite have it
all figured out you have a little bit of
doubt yourself and if all you hear is no
and all you see is darkness around you
at some point this is where a lot of
people fall down this is where a lot of
ideas die on the table because what
happens is you start believing in other
people and what they're saying more than
you believe in yourself you start
thinking these guys know what they're
talking about maybe I am crazy maybe I
don't know what I'm doing maybe this
idea really is stupid and you end up
quitting and then you see a little while
later somebody else making huge dollars
from your idea and you kick yourself and
you say that should have been me I knew
this was a good idea but you stopped
believing in yourself and you started
believing the doubters successful
entrepreneurs are the ones who at that
early phase when nobody believes in them
when all they see is darkness when they
see zero
mentum with their ideas nobody's buying
from them nobody is saying this is a
great idea in the eyes of the world
they're a total failure they haven't
done anything they don't care they keep
going every successful entrepreneur had
massive amounts of people who doubted
them and they kept going that's what
makes a difference you have to believe
in your idea and ignore the
non-believers I'm reminded of the story
of Debi fields the founder of mrs.
Fields Cookies she was a housewife and
she was happy being a mother and she was
happy to being a wife but she felt you
know there's something missing I feel
like I'm destined to do more than just
this and she thought that her future lay
in making cookies and she went to her
parents and she went there her husband
the first people I think of who do you
share ideas with first your family the
people closest to you she told them and
they said that it was a stupid idea her
parents said Debbie you have no business
going into the cookie business she they
said you've never graduated college you
don't have an MBA you don't have any
money
quit this is a stupid idea her husband
said Oh sweetie this is a stupid idea
think about that you've got the people
closest in your life telling you to quit
and most people would but not Debbie
fields she said I don't care I have a
dream I'm gonna go find a way to make it
happen so she went out and started
talking the banks she didn't have any
money she had no money herself her
family wasn't supporting her so she went
to go do it on her own she started
talking to banks and bank after bank
after bank after bank after bank said no
we're not interested thank you for
coming in
so now she's got the people closest in
her life saying it's not gonna work
she's got the external world saying it's
not gonna work and what does she do she
keeps going she doesn't get down on
herself she doesn't quit she doesn't
give up on herself she doesn't believe
in them more than she believes in
herself she believed that there's
somebody out there who wants to say yes
who sees her vision and even if there's
only one person in the world who gets
that she's gonna find that person she's
not gonna quit until she finds that
person and eventually she did she found
the banker who would support her and
fast forward to today
Debbie fields is worth half a billion
dollars from selling cookies and what
would have happened if she listened to
everybody this is important because this
is where a lot of people are you want
something more out of your life you want
something greater than what you are
right now you've got to go get it
regardless of what everybody in your
life tells you because most people face
against those odds they would have said
you know you're right
I'm just a housewife I love baking but
that's not a business this is a stupid
idea everybody tells me so so I'm not
going to do it wrong answer
you could be Debbie Fields you could be
the next great entrepreneur but you've
got to believe in your product that
you're doing the right thing and that
it's going to work out even though you
have no logical statistics or reason for
believing that right now the world will
tell you you're crazy and maybe you are
but you're a crazy person is gonna
change the world I'm working on a big
idea right now and I pitched it to some
of my friends these guys are
entrepreneurs they know what it's like
right in the business they know how hard
it is to get people to believe in you
and the bigger the idea you have
the more resistance you're gonna face
and this is a big idea and I pitched it
to them and all I got back was basically
the reasons why I wasn't gonna work and
you know what I don't have all the
answers some of those reasons are legit
but I'm gonna overcome them phase one of
this plan was to create a six to eight
minute long motivational video something
to help people believe in themselves
more something that was inspiring would
help them take action help them when
again you have all those doubters what
do you do and they've told me nobody's
gonna sit and watch this it's it's too
long you're not gonna get their
undivided attention you have to come up
with something else
this this isn't gonna work you know what
I launched it in under a week 10,000
views
crazy numbers of likes and comments and
people writing in to say Evan I needed
this video today this video has saved me
this video has helped change my life
these are real comments go look them up
go find the video on my channel it's
there it's called believe you'll find it
and what if I didn't make this video
what if I had listened to everybody and
said ah you know what man I don't know
if this isn't gonna work I guess you
guys know what you're talking about
and for me 10,000 views is nothing this
is gonna be a million of you plus video
we are gonna get a million views on this
video + and you know what I'm gonna get
next from some people well you know what
it's a good video you got 10,000 views
that's great but a million come on
that's crazy you're not gonna get a
million I'm gonna get a million it's
gonna happen it's done I'm gonna work
until I get my million views and it's
not from advertising and spamming people
it's going to come along this step along
the way with with each step with your
with your idea the progression you're
going to have
the people who just don't believe in it
and they'll say yeah you know you got
that step great but you're not gonna get
here you're not gonna get here you have
to ignore those people chances are if
you're watching this video k if you're
subscribing to my channel you're
watching these kinds of related videos
you want to change in your life you're
not happy with where you are right now
in your life you're like that Debbie
fields you've got an okay life but
you're missing something you want
something else you want something more
you believe that you can be more than
what you are right now you have
something great to offer this world and
you're not quite sure how to go out and
get it and nobody around you is helping
you you feel like you're all alone I get
that you start making changes you start
changing your life by changing your
actions by changing your beliefs and
maybe even changing the people you hang
out with because of the people in your
network are only just bringing you down
maybe they shouldn't be there anymore
if you have a great idea if you have an
idea that is needed in this world that
will change your life your family's life
your community's life the people around
you then you have to do it you have to
do it because it's the right thing to do
you have to do because this is your
chance to change your life and make a
mark you have to do it because if you
don't do it you're gonna look back on
your life from your gret and see other
people do it and say that could have
been me so make it you follow through
take action every day and ignore the
non-believers ignore the doubters
believe in yourself more than you
believe in them believe if you guys like
this video got me all bothered if you
like this video please give it a thumbs
up below I'll make more for you and let
me know what you think okay you like
these videos you got something to say
leave a comment underneath if you've
never left a comment before this is your
first chance I love to hear from you you
guys are the ones who keep me going so I
really love those comments coming in
thank you guys so much
and I'll see you soon